don't forget the semicolon javascript
uses semicolons to signal the end of
statements try console.log without the
semicolon at the end and you'll see that
it still works most JavaScript
interpreters are smart enough to guess
when you need a semicolon but they
aren't perfect so you shouldn't leave
things to chance that's good to know you
know in Python you don't have to use
semicolons at all when I was learning
JavaScript I had to keep reminding
myself to include one
yeah that's pretty common what about
this undefined line here it simply means
that the console dot log command returns
undefined telling us that console dot
log doesn't create any new data we could
save this makes sense because we only
want to use console.log to print
debugging information for example if I
had a property like document that URL it
returned a string of the pages URL yeah
we can see it enclosed in quotes telling
us that we've got a string